the next horrifying nightmare scenario
segment yeah a plague of rats you see it
was I think last month a video went
viral showing a bunch of four they like
Gibbons or something or baboons some
kind of monkey in Thailand
cherry berry monkeys name yeah and they
were fighting in the streets they're all
in yo because normally the tourists
throw food but now that there's no food
wars have emerged and and monkey monkey
gangs start fighting each other mm-hmm
like hundreds yeah hundreds like just
running it's nuts and there's other
videos too I don't have you ever seen it
of baboons like someone will throw a
Snickers bar and then they'll just all
stampede chasing after it they yeah it's
creepy stuff now I guess you can reason
with the monkeys yeah they know not to
attack you or bother you because they
know that you'll bring food so they
leave you alone mm-hmm rats on the other
hand I don't think they're gonna care
they're gonna get ravenous and hungry I
mean actually if I agree you know what
hold on I mean I think a bunch of
starving monkeys would be terribly more
terrifying than starving rats
I also agree yes because what do things
gonna happen when like well monkeys are
strong man those those monkeys could
probably mess a person up and take their
food if they're like one person's just
walking with a bag full of food and
they're hungry and they smell it it's
like them definitely take someone out
what was hundreds of them I don't know
if you guys seen these videos but it's
great hold on no let's look at this yeah
this so this is crazy those rats have
been taking to the streets in packs
sometimes in the daylight emboldened by
hunger man they're on the streets roving
warriors yeah and what happens when you
get a bunch of starving rats and they're
all diseased and they start running
after you like your food yep
they can eat humans right they can eat
anything I mean if there's like a
hundred of them I would I would be
afraid of a hundred rats coming at me
all right let's see what they say the
hill reports as the country begins to
buckle down for what experts are warning
maybe our hardest a week of the
coronavirus related deaths yet one
begins to wonder where does all of our
social isolating leave the urban
dwelling animals who depend on our food
garbage for sustenance secondarily and
perhaps even more worrying where will
those survivalists turn to when their
need for food becomes dire I I do I do
have to pause and mention pigeons yeah
pigeons are a gift to mankind you know
why they well first pigeons are garbage
incarnate and so are rats but pigeons
are funny as they fly you have a
cheeseburger in New York City no not not
you but a person and they take a bunch
of bikes and they throw it on the ground
up the garbage and then little bits of
food flop on the ground a page in comes
and then eats your garbage the garbage
is broken down in the pigeons body
becomes an egg another pigeon eats
garbage and it break you know breaks
down to become you know and that's bird
fertilizer why they're the gift to
humans no I'm still waiting for it right
so its first pigeons are literally made
of refuse their kin there it is
listen it is a biological function that
converts the garbage you throw on the
ground into a bird okay because they eat
the garbage and turn into a bird okay
where would all that garbage go if there
weren't pigeons the rats would eat it no
no I'm saying so in in I remember
thinking this you know 10-15 years ago I
was in Chicago there's a gigantic pile
of french fries I mean like an insanely
huge pile okay apparently a restaurant
just dumped out a huge thing of french
fries that for some reason okay and
there was like two or three hundred
pigeons just just tearing at it I heard
it was someone with coronavirus coughed
on it this is 15 years ago and I'm
making whatever what would we do with
these french fries if not for these
pigeons mm-hmm
the pigeons cleaned up shop man yeah it
was gone like an hour and I was like
whoa the pigeons are our garbage come to
life cleaning up the garbage and leaving
now they poop a lot I get it but the
poop is isolated in certain locations
typically and a lot of it's washed away
so the garbage literally gets turned
into birds and leaves well the the
biodegradable garbage yeah of course
what about all the rest of it well they
looking at you humans come on and myself
I'm just talking about the food stuff I
do it could you imagine if there were no
pigeons there would be just like garbage
and like food garbage all over the floor
like all over the ground everywhere you
go you know I actually it I was peeling
an orange once I was sitting I was like
walking through a park and I was like
peeling the orange and like toss and the
orange off to the side because I don't
know it feels like I'm not throwing
trash on the ground when it's a an
orange peel you know and this woman
stopped me she was like excuse me excuse
me there's a trash can right over there
and she like pointed a trash can that
was
you know I could see it over there but I
was I don't know it it had me thinking
like man am I am i littering what do you
think like fruit and orange peel yeah no
I mean maybe though imagine if like out
in the in the country or maybe in the
suburbs I don't think is a big deal
it was Central Park hmm the problem was
there there the problem is the people
there's like millions who pass through
Central Park every day that's true and
if everybody was doing it
it would get really bad yeah the animals
couldn't pick it pick it up okay yeah
see that so well let's get back to the
rats okay cuz take us out there
apparently unalloyed in New York here's
a quote they say they we spoke with
Robert Corrigan a rodent ologist who
specializes in urban rats and works with
cities around the world
to design programs for rodent management
to find out most New Yorkers have
probably never heard of this type of job
before but it's his decision that
affects their lives daily as he meets
with agencies such as mouch the MTA to
help them mitigate the rat issue on the
subway it's no small feat either
especially in cities such as New York
whose rat population has been estimated
to reach around two million I mean I
would say every time I ever went in the
subway I saw a rat Oh totally every
single time I would see one yep they do
their thing yeah quote this is actually
the first virus outbreak where we've had
to be unalloyed about rats and obviously
the reason is that everybody is shut
down the rats especially in cities like
New York Boston and Washington DC are
heavily dependent on us for their food
there's no secret here that rats for the
most part get their food directly from
us it's all our garbage in general rats
like to stay close to their burrows
which are often at ground level in
apartment floorboards alleyways
sidewalks or basements they're also
nocturnal animals and survive by
mastering their surroundings trying to
stick to familiar areas within a few
hundred feet of their home Corgan tells
changing America that when rats come out
looking for restaurant garbage and
scraps in the subway and there's none to
be found for several days in a row they
switch into survival mode the result he
says is that they will begin to show up
during the day as well as the night and
in different areas than you'd normally
then you'd normally find them due to
stress the long-term impacts of a food
shortage on urban and rep on urban rat
populations can result in three
possibilities and each one is
independent of the other because of this
there's no generalization as to what
the rats in New York City are going to
do its block-by-block and it's actually
colony by colony if this keeps going on
and the rats do not find dependable
everyday sources of food they will begin
to implode on each other they'll go into
high-stress mode and they may begin
fighting to the death and then they will
begin to cannibalize each other for
their protein jeez the rodent ologist
says that he's already seen several
cases while walking around the park rats
that have been completely eviscerated
and consumed by the others man that's
what I'm saying we think people will do
yeah and the same thing happens once the
survivors realize there's no more food
to be found in that area they may also
begin to disperse traveling quite a
distance of multiple miles than the
matter of a couple days in their hurried
search for sustenance they'll try to
find another spot where they can get
some kind of food and if they don't find
that there's they're going to simply die
but the third possibility is that they
will start following their noses
this is where I was thinking cities like
New Orleans with its popular French
Quarter typically swarmed tourists are
now seeing swarms of another kind
emboldened by hunger the city's rats
have been taking to the now deserted
streets in large packs in search of a
bite to eat this is a video oh there's a
video a video of this that looks like
whoa yeah a bunch of rats oh man they're
forming rat gangs yeah rat gangs man
yeah yeah I mean all I see is like
they're gonna find ways into people's
places apartments yep you know New York
buildings are not all new a lot of New
York buildings are not in good shape
compared to like the brand-new stuff
that's going out like they they're gonna
follow the nose and they're gonna find
their way in well he says for now take a
look at how tight the infrastructure of
your home is whether that might be a
single-family house or large apartment
building and how smart you're being
about food waste for apartment dwellers
he urges to not only check the premises
yourself but also check with your
landlord to inquire about the structure
of the space especially if the building
is located next to an alleyway or by a
sewer he says the most vulnerable spots
in your home are doors that may have
that may be a routing or don't fit
snugly into their frame allowing the
space below for rats to gnaw holes which
will allow them to enter your space he
says that they will go through any
opening where they can get to the food
they're smelling and then they will
simply try to create an info
stationed in somebody's home dude it's
gonna happen there's gonna be a story
rats are gonna break into somebody's
house yeah they're gonna freak out and
flee take over their house yep
he does I encourage everyone to look
around check out those check if there
are any kind of stray trash cans
dumpster bags or any fence going to
attract rats and eliminate them the next
thing is very important rats are very
are very smart and capable animals and
when they get desperate I tell people to
check their doors you want to make sure
your doors are fitting all the way to
the threshold and there's no gap where
they're going to allow a rodent in the
house one of the scariest possibilities
to consider when it comes to rats
invading your building may not be what
comes to mind then cutting off your
access to television rats gnaw on cables
and in fact it's been estimated that a
whopping 26% of electrical cable breaks
and 25% of fires of unknown origin in
New York City are caused by rats that
make sense it's just one of the reasons
why you want to be as smart as possible
when it comes to keeping the rodents out
of your home along with the fact they're
pretty darn hard to kill they reproduce
at a tremendous rate mating about 20
times in six hours producing four to
seven liters of ten rats each year
beyond that they're Neo phobic meaning
that the those traps you set and that
poison you laid out probably won't work
very well hmm Corgan says that if you do
happen to catch a glimpse of a rat in
your home especially if there are
children president it is certainly no
DIY job call your local exterminator as
soon as you can we're all going to get
through this and hopefully over time who
knows maybe they'll teach us a lesson to
better dispose of our trash and keep our
buildings tighter you did I see from
this what we're not going back to normal
no way thank goodness though right for
this for sure
well there's yeah there's a lot that
needs to be you know our overpour
consumption is is crazy well no I think
that'll come back for sure
I just think open odd I think people are
gonna be you get a couple stories about
rats raiding somebody's house and
they're gonna take their trash and
recycling much more seriously okay and
that's that's a good thing
right not rats bedding great rats in
people's homes but you know people
cleaning up and doing a better job
people are gonna shake hands anymore
yeah that's good well I guess you know
maybe we'll bow or something live long
and prosper
yeah just do that a [ __ ] thing yeah
everyone knows what it means now they're
talking about rats where are the pigeons
like we jumped by pigeons but that you
said it though they can fly so they can
fly to heat bugs in fields fly there
probably will migrate away from cities
yeah and then migrate back when the
whole machine gets kicked up again yeah
I mean for that matter what about all of
the animals you know sparrows cats maybe
maybe the answer to the problem is to
just to unleash all of the shelter cats
into New York City yeah I thought I
heard I heard you know I heard from
somewhere that all the shelter's were
empty for 30 years in New York cuz
everyone's adopting the cats like Wow
and dogs that's kind of the job for cats
I know it was a dog shelter that was
reading it about there's a joke from The
Simpsons was that they had the pigeon
eating lizards so they're like well
really snakes then will released weasels
then we'll release dogs then we'll
release gorillas yeah and they're like
but then you know they were like what do
you how do you get rid of the gorillas
and Skinner is like I don't know sad I
think with Skinner he's like that's the
best part when winter comes they simply
freeze to death like they keep bringing
in more animals go to the old ones well
it's kind of crazy that humans have
brought with them everywhere they go
these animals yeah it's true it's like
you couldn't get rid of the rats before
they got in your boat and you brought
them on the boat dude they intentionally
brought rabbits to Australia they have
no they had no natural predators there
really yeah and the rabbits just went
nuts like I don't know about that
Australia's like they did build a rabbit
the last level of Earth and I mean like
the most difficulty the highest
difficulty setting you think there would
be tons of predators but rabbits weird
ones
what did someone like bring like frogs
there or something
all sorts of didn't happen like to some
Island down in the South Pacific there
was like a snake that ate every little
thing so then now
spiders have nothing that eats them so
now spiders are like taking over the
trees so there's places like Webb's are
all crazy webs are so massive because
there's just these snakes and the
spiders and that's it spiders eat all
the little insects
the snakes eat all the like rodents and
rabbits and everything I imagine that
there's like there's a there's an
elephant somewhere talking to his
elephant friends
and he's like have you seen these places
where humans are out of control it's
like they take the rocks and stack them
up it's crazy there's rocks everywhere
right it's like we're talking about the
webs of spiders cuz they grow out of
control yep you know what man I would
not want to be in a city right now
because we don't we so we live in the
suburbs and there's no just like street
refuse so sure we have we are probably
have turkey problems like we have yes we
have Turkey whoa whoa problems problem
is a loose term we saw some some wild
turkeys yesterday - yesterday though so
if we get like 50 no but one day there
was like 16 or 17 oh really
yeah cool yeah like last month is that a
gaggle rafter is a rafter after and
they're like but like it's like is this
like a truce here you know like
everyone's in agreement you leave the
turkeys alone them do their thing yeah
don't mess with the turkeys I'll tell
you what man when you apocalypse comes
those turkeys are gonna be food triggers
are gone they're not rats they're Birds
yeah all right you know my vegan at the
door today I just do they lay eggs
oh yeah you just catch him keep them and
you put them in a pen and yeah then you
go you get fresh eggs I think it's
really dumb they don't allow you to have
livestock in the certain areas so like
we can't have chickens here I want some
fresh eggs yeah I'm seeing on Twitter I
mean people are making fresh bread I
just walk down the street there's
there's goats what's like blocks from
here yeah we got room for goats I just I
just saw goats we could get goats
I don't want goats you don't oh that's
right they scream my gosh are loud yeah
yeah we used to live next to some goats
and they would yell everywhere wasn't
some it was like straight up farm they
were loud no they didn't smell so much
but loud yeah maybe not about to try to
do a goat maybe maybe we're missing
something here what are we missing
maybe we can harness the rat power go on
well I mean the rats our energy of some
sort yeah okay they move around I know
but like you know can we put my little
treadmills or like yeah what do think I
just I just watched a video mom I just
watched the video about eating crickets
okay we did like think they make cricket
flour right they grow sustainable
crickets they feed them healthy things
and they mill them into a fine powder
and apparently it tastes like snot there
because I can nut flour it does
imagine being
build into a flower grinder by the
Soylent Green but you know I mean
everybody in the world eats bugs 80% so
I actually tried to buy some and it's
Amazon sold out what yeah it was weird
like unavailable and I wonder if like
survivalists bought all the cricket
flour I'm like regular flour still
exists guys yeah but it's high in
proteins got like I think like triple
the protein of regular flour - super
yeah and you can use it for baking and
everything as weird oh I went to Amazon
it was gone so you know I don't know but
but what the point is
I mean we're we're not big and you know
bug eaters but apparently you can mill
crickets into flour we got all these
rats run around if we do nothing they're
gonna invade me those homes what should
we do I mean uses exterminate them and
then just what do you do with a lot
equate font you uh once you cook them
out so let's do silent silent rat rat
yeah what I mean can you if you cooked a
rat would it get rid of the disease in
the parasites yeah wouldn't it probably
not the Paris well pork has parasites in
it yeah he's advised you to cook it for
a really long gross here's here's that
here's a funny thing here's a funny
thing I would I have no problem eating
bugs right I don't I wouldn't eat a rat
like a New York rat I wouldn't eat at
all what would you eat like a farm
raised
free-range rat yeah I guess yeah that's
fair I wouldn't eat a cricket off the
ground in New York yeah and if like
someone grew farm crickets and the like
chocolate cover you're like roasted or
something okay you know that's like a
normal thing
you don't eat dirty things that's the
thing right yeah the problem with New
York well I think I think the problem
with rodents is that they're having a
fat in them and so it's actually you
don't rabbit starvation that's gamey you
know rabbit starvation is no duh so like
in Venezuela I think it was Venezuela
they said you start eating your pets or
even your rabbits okay but rats are too
lean I'm I'm sorry
rabbits are too lean so if you only eat
rabbits you don't get enough fat in your
diet and like you can actually starve to
death because it's just yes you can do
yeah so too much protein will mess with
your kidneys no interesting yeah yeah so
maybe yeah everyone's talking someone
brought up the the hantavirus which is
literally getting it from rats don't eat
rats everybody yeah a virus that was
caused by a bat so I
think we should probably be eating any
rats no but I do think America Americans
for the most part have a bias towards
what they eat definitely did against
like I that we're talking mines before
like Fear Factor mm-hmm I would watch
Fear Factor and they're like you have to
eat the intestines of a pig and I'd be
alive so so food be out so food you let
me to eat food I'll eat the food I got
no problem eating it yeah you know but
but then and the whole thing is like
eating animals in general I guess we're
you know kind of bring it into that
subject but it's like as a society we
are okay with eating certain animals and
in others were totally not yeah you know
so in some places cows are sacred you
don't eat house like you eat cows you're
disgusting but we're like oh well it's a
cow like whatever it's a burger you know
but then when someone same with dogs and
cats they're animals yep but some some
people some countries eat them and
they've you know different like eating a
chicken and no and then the people
freaked out and it's like don't you eat
meat you eat meat don't you like why you
freaking out because you have they eat
what you consider a pet you know it is a
weird it is what's your situation yeah I
I I don't I don't like the idea of
eating dogs because I think dogs are
man's best friend okay
but what am I gonna impose my will upon
entire nation I disagree with it
well the tiger king his his best friend
was a cat I don't think we should either
well no I think I and and and to that to
that extent you know there you know it's
true it's a cultural thing like I think
of like deer it's a cultural and things
you hunt existed available to us we're
acceptable but you know what the bigger
issue is America in general has just
drifted towards like a primarily meat
based diet mic and dairy right so we we
disagree you know to a certain degree on
like you know undying stuff I don't
think from a libertarian point of view I
think from a personal health choice
point of view yeah but I think we both
agree that Americans over consume
absolutely you think more so than I do I
think you know a portion of your diet
should be should be meat and it should
mostly be like leafy greens and fresh
vegetables whoa whoa i I think that
everybody needs to do research on what
their own body I mean at a point yeah
that's
that's what I always say I am vegan for
myself I'm not vegan for you okay I'm
I'm doing it for me I feel better I live
in a world that I can do this very
easily I don't have to eat meat so I
don't I'm not I'm not I'm not eating the
bigger issue is what do your own
research and eat whatever you feel
healthy eating like yeah I'm cool with
it if you want to go hunt some food more
power to eat we just watched we were
watching an old episode of Penn &
Teller's BS yeah said the name of a TV
show on YouTube right and it was one guy
who's like he was morbidly obese and he
was getting sleeping pills couldn't
understand why he couldn't he couldn't
sleep right and it's like dude you don't
need sleeping pills you need to like
Americans go to the store and they're
like what should I eat today I know a
double cheeseburger with bacon and a
large fry and and also a super large
sugar soda yeah sugar water right it's
like but you know it's interesting as
Millennials have stopped drinking soda
awesome yeah they're drinking mostly
water now I soda companies ain't happy
it's true yeah I haven't had a soda in a
long time I mean there was a someone had
a rum and coke here earlier so there was
some coke in the house and I was like oh
now I was like this is so sweet you know
I have it I had to go drink some water
yeah well we certainly leave it up from
the red apocalypse into fresh diets but
we'll stop it there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you